okay pop quiz we're gonna play a game
called is it anime I'm gonna show you
clip and you're gonna tell me is it
anime so first we got this and I mean
this is the oldest trick in the book
Panty and Stocking
yeah it looks like a cartoon butts come
on it was made by Gainax Hiroyuki am i
she's teamed for the may trigger so is
it anime yeah of course the next we got
this which you know it looks exactly
like anime moves like anime but it was
made in China and China's obviously not
Japan so is it anime no even though this
looks exactly like any other anime I'd
watch and lastly we got this and I think
this is pretty obvious I mean this is
just Batman it's an American cartoon so
obviously it's not anime actually hold
on a second this movie return of the
Joker was actually animated by TMS
entertainment that featured works from
the likes of Hiroyuki Ali Yama who
worked on other feature films like Akira
so um is it anime [ __ ] for years now the
debate of what does and doesn't count as
anime has been a prevalent discussion in
our community that has been played with
heated debates of how we should
correctly label and categorize certain
shows while the technical origins of the
word anime is and always has been just
the Japanese word for animation that
hasn't stopped it from being used as a
label here to describe shows and movies
in a certain subculture the subculture
of animation and comics from Japan and
while most people in the fandom knew
what you meant when he talked about
anime the exact definition has always
been a bit vague
I think there's been enough discussion
now around our community that most
people are aware that it's not that
simple
whether you talk about breaking down
anime by its art style intended audience
ethnic origin of creative staff country
was produced in it's all very muddy if
you have a personal clear-cut definition
of what anime is I guarantee there are
dozens of examples that will break your
rule or have some shows that fall into
your rules that you wouldn't really be
happy calling anime at all
because that's just how broad this
medium is however there hasn't really
stopped the majority from agreeing that
shows like Teen Titans or avatar while
obviously anime inspired were not anime
as they weren't from Japan and for the
longest time that was the consensus no
matter what discussion points were
brought up with the general agreement
being anime is just animation that was
made in Japan though over time I've seen
that way of thinking slowly changing our
community right now it feels like we're
in a crossroads where the perception of
what anime is and the usage of the word
is shifting to the extent where if
avatar had been made in the coming years
I believe there's a good chance it could
have been considered an anime as the
need to correctly categorize anime and
its general definition changes in the
current environment and to understand
why I think it's important to understand
why we felt the need to correctly
categorize it in the first place as fans
I'm sure I speak for a lot of us who
grew up watching anime when I say that
we were drawn to it because it felt
different I could tell there was
something that separated the likes of
Hey Arnold Dexter's Laboratory and Ed
Edd and Eddy to Dragon Ball Z Digimon
and cardcaptors and when I grew order
and actually got properly invested into
the medium anime was this strange exotic
foreign thing that you couldn't find
anywhere else not just the art star they
had a unique way of telling stories
directing action it was weird it was the
only place which did 2d animation that
didn't just appeal to kids and because
of this being an anime fan meant
something because it meant that you into
a medium that not many others were and I
feel like this is where a lot of the
desire to categorize anime comes from
for the longest time that wasn't really
a concept of a casual anime fan so when
you said you were into anime there was a
clear distinction between these shows
and everything else so even when things
like Avatar Teen Titans came along there
was a simple line we could draw that
served as a point of common interest for
us to gather around we were into foreign
media that came from Japan and these
didn't come from Japan but things have
changed drastically as the fandom and
medium have grown that point of common
interest between anime fans has dwindled
not only has the fandom become a much
larger less unified group but anime
itself has just become a more accepted
medium for mainstream entertainment
there are a casual fan there are
hardcore fans you got Christoph Waltz
asking kids in the I she's single
Elon Musk casually wearing a khaki Guri
shirt the whole subculture of anime has
expanded so far past just the small
group of nerds watching these these
cartoons and this appeal has grown too
wide to fit under one umbrella not only
that but the industry itself is far
closer to our shores and it ever has
been crunchyroll are on the production
committee to a handful of shows every
year Netflix are just straight-up
funding their own original projects
radient is an anime airing right now
that is based on a manga made by a
French dude FLCL season two and three
were only available in English dubbed
months before a Japanese broadcast thus
right if Japanese viewers wanted to
watch it early they would have had to
watch it with Japanese subtitles
not to mention the increasing number of
international staff members that are now
actively working in the industry held
the other day I was lucky enough to hang
out with Kevin penguin an Australian
bloke who composed the soundtrack to
made an abyss one of the most critically
acclaimed anime orestes of 2017
that was recorded in a sound studio in
Vienna Austria huh the era where anime
was this exotic foreign thing that we
had no involvement or influence in is
dying as other countries get more
actively involved in the industry shifts
from a purely Japanese one to an
international one and as we see this
shift there's less of a need to strictly
differentiate it based on geological
origin it becomes more remove until more
of a concept it becomes a brand
something you can't easily describe but
can be instantly recognized and marketed
as a thing that fits in with the culture
we've created and I don't mean to
cheapen the cultural significance and
history of Japanese animation is just as
the medium evolves that's kind of what
it's starting to feel like and I know
that's kind of a broad statement so to
explain where I'm coming from I'm gonna
talk about the tale of two shows Netflix
is Castlevania and crunchy rolls hi
Guardian spice these are two completely
Western produced shows that been
marketed towards an anime audience that
couldn't have got a more polarizing
reception Castlevania for the most part
was really well received in I on a
mission unity I've met so many people
that had no idea wasn't produced in
Japan and even those who did only had
praise for how well it did with his
action in animation even paying homage
to legendary Japanese animators so a lot
of people even though they know this
wasn't made in Japan consider this an
anime and as for High Guardian spice so
really what's the difference between
these two shows from a production
perspective there's not actually much
both our Western animation funded by
streaming companies in an attempt to
produce their own original content that
have no affiliation with Japan at all so
the more I think about it the more I
think it's really just down to their
marketing and branding Netflix is an all
encompassing media Titan and Castlevania
was marked it as an animation that
specifically appealed to anime fans to
them it didn't really matter where it
came from they knew that if you liked
this and this then you're probably gonna
like this and that's all that really
matters so who cares if this shows under
the anime tag with all these other shows
from their perspective this is anime on
the flip side you have high Guardian
spice where you can blame some of the
fault of the lackluster announcement
trailer but at its core I think a lot of
you will agree with me when I say that
High Guardian spy
just doesn't look or feel like anime at
all and there's no inherent problem with
this except for the fact that it's being
made by crunchyroll so even if it's not
their intention to make an anime they
can't market this to anyone else but an
anime audience because it's crunchyroll
they are the anime streaming service
their users are there for anime anime is
their brand if Cronshaw had made
castlevania and netflix made hai
Guardian spice there would be no
controversy around it but as it stands
hi Guardian spice was so far removed
from what their audience expected that
of course they received backlash for it
and I actually think this was such a
simple problem a lot of the shitstorm
could have been avoided if they'd just
branded it a bit differently
[Music]
granted castlevania is already out and
high Guardian spice is literally one
announcement trailer but I seem to
remember that when Castlevania was
announced it was met with excitement and
curiosity and hi Guardian spice won't
even be the first American produced show
that's streaming on crunchyroll but
there was no controversy when they made
the decision to stream Ruby on that
platform and that just brings me back to
my point there is no technical divide
between these two shows aside from one
feels like anime and one doesn't and if
watching Castlevania feels the same as
watching all the other seasonal anime
that streaming who really cares
going back to Avatar the reason it was
the show to spark the discussion in the
first place was cause it was the first
show that genuinely felt very anime
despite being produced in America for
primarily an American audience but today
what even is the intended audience when
TV is no longer a factor and shows are
being streamed internationally in
multiple languages which is why I think
there's been a subtle shift in
perception from you can call this an
anime it's not from Japan - yeah
whatever
I don't care where it's made I'm still
gonna put it in my top 20 list of anime
last year however you view anime is hard
to deny that we see the anime trademark
and branding in a lot more places used
in ways that would appeal to our
community doki doki was an internet
sensation that capitalized on a darker
look at waifu culture you've got league
of legends hiring PA works to make an
anime pv for them Hollywood is trying
their damned hardest to make anime work
in live-action [ __ ] if you want to sell
me a product just brandy with some anime
waifu's and suddenly I'm interested yeah
I'm that easy alright don't judge me and
this is me only really focusing on
Western attempts to
to the fandom but it equally applies to
countries in the East I think it's only
a matter of time before we get a
breakout hit Chinese anime I think it's
only a matter of time before we get some
kind of korean manhwa adaptation hell
having lived in thailand for the past
two years I've seen some really [ __ ]
talented animators in Southeast Asia so
I wouldn't be surprised if something
eventually comes out from that region
and when it does is anyone gonna care if
we call this an anime or that an anime
and would that stop you from being
interested in it whether you do decide
to simply categorize man hua man far or
webtoons Castlevania or King's avatar
there's no denying that these are all
targeted towards the anime and manga
subculture it's all the same brand
so the question shifts from does this
count as anime term or off is this
something that's gonna appeal to the
anime fandom which is what I feel the
mentality of future productions will
have in the matter what country it's
made in in the end the category of what
counts won't be decided by some
fictional scholars drawing the line of
what is and is an anime as much as the
mods in our anime I've tried to do so in
the past it's us it's what the general
consensus agrees on and the exact word
used such as this can shift depending on
culture environment and time no matter
how many times we were told that the
word otaku had severe negative
connotations in Japan it didn't stop it
from becoming an all-encompassing buzz
word to describe anime fans here in the
West [ __ ] does anyone remember when
calling someone a weeaboo was a massive
insult and now everyone calls themselves
a weeb I call myself a [ __ ] wave I am
a [ __ ] wave even though I've chosen
to use the word brand to describe the
entity anime is turning into I don't
mean to say that it's just a brand anime
is and always will be associated with
Japanese animation and honestly I don't
think it should be any other way but as
we move forward I believe that the clear
definition and context we use the word
in is just gonna get more muddled and
broad because even if you don't
subscribe to the idea that anime should
be this all-encompassing word that
labels everything that remotely
resembles the Japanese shows we grew up
with the deeper you dig the more you see
that from the beginning anime has always
been more than just a single art style a
single genre a single way of
storytelling a single method of
animation and as time goes on more
they're just coming from a single
country
[Music]
hey guys
will you go anywhere I do have a quick
announcement this year I'm gonna be
guesting up mo makan from May 23rd to
26th for those you that don't know
merkon is an anime gaming and comic
convention in Atlanta Georgia with one
of the biggest gaming halls in any
convention so if you want a chance to
meet me there there's a link in the
description where you can register and
I'm looking forward to it since it's my
first time in that area of the state so
I hope to see you there anyway with that
said thank you very much to our
illustris just stare unless you're a
sweet us from I'm sorry I probably
pronounced that very long epic Mik
supreme Saiyan Nicholas
Tatum Mike elfin sisters one zero zero
eight six and everyone else on my
patreon to helping support me for this
month and making this video possible no
further updates from me today but for
future reference if you do want me to
attend the convention near you the best
thing to do is just to let your
convention know I don't guess the too
many conventions every year but I look
for any excuse I can to get out of the
office and endowment anyway that's it
from me I've been gigging and I'll see
you all next time